fashiru would go so hard right now. That's what the current drama
sphere needs is is just completely overtly avowed fascist Emiru.
Okay. Starting OTK was the most profound and largest mistake
that I have ever made in my entire life. I'm not a virus, but
I'm also not a disease. I'm the inoculation. If you're lying
to a girl, the best way to do it is to emotionally manipulate
them. If you can activate their emotions on something, you can
tell them anything that they want to hear.
How are we doing, guys? How we doing? How we feeling today? Bro,
that throwaway tweet went intergalactic.
Look at the Look at all this on this throwaway tweet, dude. Look
at this. Look at this. Look at this guy.
Hold on. Here it is.
Almost 50,000 likes, 20 million views, dude. 20.6 million views.
50,000. Bro, the internet hates Emiru. We love Msk here, but
you suddenly get you suddenly understand entirely how her and
Msk stayed together for so long cuz they have the very they have
very similar mentalities. Okay. Just this like total victimhood
sometimes that pops out. It's very very very funny. I was hanging
out with one of my friends while I was getting ready this morning
and uh they stream a little bit and they said that so like their
stream doesn't even know that they're friends with me, right?
They're they're a small streamer. Their stream doesn't know that
we're friends.
And they were telling me that they're like, "Yeah, for some reason
people like always bring me up in my chat even though they don't
know that we're like friends." And they says that they were talking
about the Epstein files like just being like, "Oh yeah, that's
like disgusting. It's crazy." And someone in their chat was like,
>> "Wow, you have more balls than emer to talk about the
Epstein files." And they were like, [laughter] >> like
apparently some tiny streamer's chat. She's just watching that
for some reason. Someone talks to her and she just has to bring
it up on her stream. She She has to know that it's just it's
stupid as to bring this up, right? She has to know >> what
I was like that has to have been satire or something cuz like
what the [__] are they talking about? [laughter]
>> Like what? Um, am I like I'm like the government as
well now, I guess. Yo, Galaxy player, thanks for the 4 months.
Yeah, they said they didn't say anything cuz like they don't
even know that we're friends, but they're like what?
I don't know. Sus awfully quiet.
>> Wow. Didn't miss tweet out ice in response to this?
He did. Yeah, he did. It's a little funny. Okay,
I just want to point out once again, we always have to do this
PSA. These are not plushies. These are weapons. Okay, when Misgiv
gets the restraining order against Emiru, they will take all
of these plushies. These these
weapons of war over here, okay? True weapons of war in the corner
over here. All right. One of the one of these little beads in
the eyes, one of these little eye beads hits you in your eye.
Okay. And you're done. Destroys your cornea. Okay. You start
hallucinating like tectone, it's over for you. Okay,
she's of mass destruction. Yes, the skitso post is insane. You
got to check it out. Okay, hold on. You said it was on this tweet
right here. Here's what you need to know about this grifter viewer
called Emmy. Her friend/podcast co-host Asmin Gold is a shutin
Nazi viewb. Her friend/podcast co-host Teone is a who can't own
a gun in Texas for 10 years. Her friend Lucari is a Okay.
Uh, all right.
That one was That one's getting 20,000 likes. Then you said there's
another one that her view botting is insane.
Hold on. Her view botting is insane. Is her view botting insane?
Hold on. Good evening, Axe. Jordan.
Wait. I don't know if I trust you. Oh, the Emmy Skitsos. Oh,
the Emmy Skitzos started going after Asminold. Uhoh.
Uhoh.
[clears throat] Uhoh.
played uh you know TFT team fight tactics. I don't know how I
got involved playing that game. [music]
>> Egg Emmy Asmin Gold. Okay.
>> You know what I've been doing on my my days off recently
is I usually still have to be on my computer to like do like
work. I'll just buy my friends. I'll buy them games that I like
playing and make them stream it for me on Discord. I'm gonna
be honest. Like I was on a Discord call with somebody. Like I
was like streaming POE to them until 7:30 in the morning. All
right. I stayed up so late last night. Hey, I played three games
of Mega Bonk with my friend and I I got on Discord and I was
like I I was screen sharing and I just dying on map one. I go
to SK's party. I
Oh [__] bro. The Emmy skitsos are so powerful.
They're so insanely powerful. Okay,
these people are like their own sphere. They don't interact almost
anywhere
They just they just know everything that all these OTK people
do. It's actually insane to watch that you would connect these
things over time and space
>> put together like the league stuff.
>> I haven't yet. I don't know. Um I'm going to probably
lay down, maybe take a nap, and uh I will be back on tomorrow.
>> How's it going?
>> Are we late?
>> I'm probably going to give this I'll give the second
one away to someone. I don't know who yet. This I picked this
one up last night from the store. >> Did you get the Switch,
too? No, I didn't. I went to a uh It's actually kind of funny.
I went to the midnight release of the Switch last night with
somebody else and they got their Switch, but I didn't get my
Switch and so home. I got home about like probably 3:00 in the
morning almost. No, no, not too two cuz I I had to do a meeting
at 2 a.m. Actually, I didn't buy it. It was given to me. I I
I have a Switch, too. And I will repay that debt. >> I
got 65 Zack Roar raids. >> True. Absolutely. You don't
want you want to be sent for someone who's not your girlfriend.
Well, I mean sometimes maybe maybe to get her, you know, like
you got to catch them, It's like, you know, like whenever you're
hunting and like you're trying to capture like a like a rabbit,
right? Or something like that. Or a [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
like a raccoon. You could say uh you put um [__]
food under a box, right? And then like as soon as they get the
box, you get the box, right? I can't I hate to say this, but
if you're lying to a girl, the best way to do it is to emotionally
manipulate them. If you can activate their emotions on something,
you can tell them anything that they want to hear and you can
get them to >> Dude, why why would this be included right
at the end?
Um, okay. That I mean, listen,
I'll just say again,
these people are actually the people who follow Emiru like know
everything about her, know everything about everyone around her.
They'll connect these things all the time. Okay,
this is I don't know if any of this is true, by the way. We're
just watching total Emmy skitso propaganda right here. That's
like Emmy. Yeah, a lot of people were getting mad at Emmy for
not wanting to comment on politics. I'll talk about that later
on. I want to talk about right now, but uh yeah, I did see that.
It's just stupid. It's And it's of course, right, the usual suspects,
right? The same usual hostile, aggressive bullies on the internet.
Uh it's like you're either with us or you're against us. Uh you
know, you either have to tell us our opinion back to us or we
attack you as if you have the opposite one, which is it. They're
they're terrible people and uh I I don't know why anybody really
I I don't see how people that do that can think that they're
in the right at all. I I don't but uh it's very it's it's very
frustrating for me. I just thought she could not mention it.
Like literally just don't respond to political questions at all.
That's all you got to do, right? It's super easy. Hey, you don't
want to talk about politics? Cool. Then don't talk about politics.
How easy is that? Boom. Done. You don't want to talk about politics.
Guess what? You don't have to talk about politics. You don't
have to talk about politics at all. Straight up.
But then if you're going to say, "Well, uh, actually, if you
come to online influencers for politics that you're
u, by the way, you don't even know this, but that was Emir trying
to take a at Asold. Okay, they had a fight." And she's basically
like, if you need some online streamer with no education, no
background in politics whatsoever to tell you what your political
opinion should be, you're she's actually super based there and
nobody realizes it, right?
Absolutely nobody realizes it. She was just totally taking a
Asmin Gold. Hey, every Asmin Gold viewer, you're But nobody could
see it. for me to see something like that, especially whenever
it's someone who's not even involved. Like it's basically like
these are the people that say that, well, nothing is politics
if it's my opinion, but anything that you agree with isn't politics.
I find this to be very problematic. I don't like it at all. And
uh she's not political streamer. No, she she's not even involved
in that at all. Like she has nothing to do with that. And I you've
got to keep in mind the reason why a lot of people don't talk
about politics is it's because they don't want to seem uneducated
or like get their opinion out there. Like I mean Emy's a big
streamer, right? Why do you want to use your platform to talk
about something that you're not informed about? And so really,
I mean, what if somebody doesn't feel comfortable >> Somebody
give me the clip of Asminagold talking about how he doesn't need
to get informed, how he likes to not be informed, how he likes
to just give his reaction. You openly admitted you do research
or read articles outside of Twitter. How can you shamelessly
tell others to read more?
I don't need to understand whatever article you want me to read.
All I need to understand is human psychology and incentives.
And incentives and human psychology are the deciding factors
of how people will behave. Uh, I don't need to read
>> your little your little special book or your Wikipedia.
>> Here, let me pull it back. >> He's a big streamer,
right? Why do you want to use your platform to talk about something
that you're not informed about? And so really, I mean, what if
somebody doesn't feel comfortable talking about something then
any
Okay. I mean, these are not actually related. I can pull that
up as like a gotcha. They're not like actually related, unfortunately.
Right? You know what I'm saying? Like I could see what he's trying
to say. He's trying to say like, "Well, if you if you feel uninformed,
you don't want to speak about it, then don't."
Which is like maybe fair. But again, if that's your if that's
the case, just shut up. Just shut up. It's so easy to just shut
up, man. Come on, man.
Apparently, Msk did the uh
he he watched the skitso video. Hold on.
Uh, you know, TFT, Team Fight Tactics. I don't know how I got
involved playing that game. [music]
>> Keep in mind, Amaru's sister is trans. And, uh, know
the takes about Asmold when it comes to trans women, by the >> Actually,
incredibly uninformed opinion from Msk. Unfortunately, there
as gold. This is the one non-chud opinion that Asmold has, actually.
And kind of, but hold on. But hold on.
actually sort of illuminating that Emiru has a transistor apparently
and
as the one non-shut opinion happens to align really closely.
We tweaked that a little bit is msg gives us gives us some information
some new information. Oh, how did he come to that opinion? That's
what he's saying. Oh, maybe maybe he is saying that >> team
fight tactics. I don't know how I got involved. >> I don't
No, that's not what he's saying. I don't think that's what he's
saying at all. He assumes that asoldold has like the chut opinion
on it for sure. Please tell me. [music]
>> The funny thing about the funniest thing about this
to me is that these exact people made like like Msk insane. Like
they they made Msk lose his mind. Like he he was so stressed
about these people like stalking him all over the place and now
he's not involved and he's dancing.
He's like that at least it's not happening to me anymore. He's
just >> He's trans. And uh know the takes about Asmigold
when it comes to trans women. By the way, >> team fight
tactics. I don't know how I got involved playing that game.
>> This is a girl that cosplays and does LGBTQ content.
[music]
>> Dude,
[laughter]
dude, I'm sorry.
It's just super funny. Ah,
it's so funny how spiteful he is. Like, he's just totally He's
totally openly spite driven. Okay. Totally openly spite driven.
It's awesome. >> You know what I'm doing on like my days
off, [laughter] >> dude? Also, that freeze frame right
there. Is that Rich Campbell? Didn't he or didn't he?
No, he didn't. He didn't. >> What I'm doing on my my days
off is I usually still have to be on my computer to like do like
work. I'll just buy my friends. I'll buy them games that I like
playing and make them stream it for me on Discord. I'm gonna
be honest. Like, I was on a Discord call with somebody. Like,
I was like streaming POE to them until 7:30 in the morning. All
right. I stayed up so late last night. Hey, I played three games
of Mega Bonk with my friend and I I got on Discord and I was
like I I was screen sharing and I just kept dying on map one.
I go to SN's party. I haven't really decided yet. I don't know.
Um I'm going to probably lay down, maybe take a nap and uh I
will be back on tomorrow.
>> How's it going?
>> You guys are so [__] good at your job. It's
crazy,
>> dude. He knows, by the way. He knows because he took
all of the like precautions to not get stalked by these people
and they like pull up the Austin traffic cams, track his vehicle
going over to where they suspect Emirou lives based on, you know,
getting a picture from her house that showed like one quarter
centimeter of sunlight coming from outside. And based on how
the shadow was cast, they could calculate the position of the
sun in the sky and figure out, you know, within a 3m radius where
Emiru would live. And then they saw him driving in that direction.
They're like, "We got you now." Based on that, they started watching
other traffic cams, saw Emmy leave that same place, okay, at
different times. And then they slowly narrowed it down to figure
out precisely where she lived. That's This is like the level
of NSA autism that's going on to track Emiru's movements, which
by the way, this all sounds crazy, but I I'm not even I'm I'm
barely I'm barely being hyperbolic. I'm like barely being hyperbolic.
Okay.
>> And if only these people had met Legal Mindset earlier,
they could have gotten some tips on how to dodge people like
>> I'm probably going to give this I'll give the second
one away to someone. I don't know who yet. This I picked this
one up last night from the store. >> Did you get the Switch,
too? No, I didn't. I went to a uh It's actually kind of funny.
I went to the midnight release of the Switch last night with
somebody else and they got their Switch, but I didn't get my
Switch. >> I just flipped the Switch. Switch. Switch. I
wonder why Asmin went non-stop hard at me for four days straight
about the fact that I assaulted Emer quote unquote, but yet he
still hasn't really talked about Techone at all. In fact, I don't
think he's really even denounced him at all. Interesting. It's
interesting how he hardly even said anything about Lucari, besides
the fact that you should probably get a second PC. But why did
you go after me for things that were about 130th as bad as Techone
and about 1,000th as bad as Lucari? But you went after me nonstop
for 4 days straight on some on Emiru,
>> Wow. I do actually wonder that. That is a good question.
I'm happy here. I'm happy Miz is here to ask questions like this.
I wonder why Asmin Gold got so so
upset about that. Also,
uh little little warning to Asminold.
If that is happening, Asmin Gold, I just watch your back, okay?
Cuz Tech's got a dagger with your name on it. All right? And
it's coming. Whether it comes today, tomorrow, a month from now,
a year from now, if you're with Emirou, Tech's got a dagger with
your name carved into it. Okay? It's It's primed. It's ready
for your back
if that's the case. >> Which were just he says, she says,
but you didn't say a damn thing about Techone and Lucari. Huh.
Interesting. I wonder. It's like you're in love. But I'm so confused.
I'm so confused why you didn't say >> No dagger. Court
took him away. That's wrong. Court actually left the the swords,
all the weeb. They left all that with tectone. Okay. They just
took the
We're still watching the Asigold defenses. Azul is in the middle
of one of his defenses. I do believe he he goes back to this
emu topic a couple times. So, let's just keep watching this here.
I'll roll it back a little bit. And uh she's not political streamer.
No, she she's not even involved in that at all. Like she has
nothing to do with that. And you got to keep in mind the reason
why a lot of people don't talk about politics is it's because
they don't want to seem uneducated or like get their opinion
out there. Like I mean Emy's a big streamer, right? Why do you
want to use your platform to talk about something that you're
not informed about? And so really, I mean, what if somebody doesn't
feel comfortable talking about something, then anybody who's
trying to bully them into talking about it really doesn't actually
want them to talk about it. What they want is for that person
to agree with them and then repeat their opinion. They want to
effectively co-opt other people's platforms, bully them into
agreeing with them or saying the same thing that they do. And
if you don't let them co-opt and take over your platform and
tell you what to say, then they just make up lies about you and
try to destroy your reputation. Now, I find this to be just completely
like th this is the m
um are there lies being told about Emmy? I
What what are the lies being told about Emmy?
Denims is a good example of what he is saying.
Here's the Denims Emmy clip about Ethan. What?
Hold on. I didn't know this. Is there a Is there a Denim's Emiru
rivalry >> Well, reacts are a little scary cuz I saw that
um some people are getting sued for reactions, but I mean it's
like a a different case than what I I do, I guess. So,
>> surely it's different.
>> Mr. Daily wouldn't sue me. We're homies.
He likes my tweets sometimes.
>> Yo, Dylan, thanks for 33 months. Not or it's it's people
that like maliciously
>> react like they react to people they >> I I'm
sorry.
Call me Call me crazy,
but this is just another tick in the box for the Emmy skitsos.
Okay, maybe they are unaware of this, but there's no way Emiru
actually gives a about the H3 lawsuits. There's no way she would
give any amount of a about that. She's been talked to about that
by somebody in private Discord calls. Okay, I'm I'm telling you
100%.
We all know that, right? We all know that's the case.
Like 100%
she is just talking to Asmin Gold. Asmin Gold is just giving
her his opinion when they have conversations >> like watch
me so that they don't get any views
like yeah you you can't do that
>> that's not good
>> and Rose
>> this is this is uh this is Emmy or sorry this is literally
any of these people actually I just want I just want us to light
this candle okay she needs to come out fully in support of Asmin
Golden Techone fully in support of Ice All
Fash fashiru
would go so hard right now. That's what the current drama sphere
needs is is just completely overtly avowed fascist Emiru. Okay.
Give us your opinion right now. Emiru.
Explain to us how you need concentration camps in the USA to
deal with all of these illegals. Okay. I need it. I need it right
now.
Right now,
please.
God, that would go so hard. That would be awesome.
That's all she had to do. >> Should I do a scramble first?
>> Ali Kitty, so what are your thoughts on ice? Hassad
Okay. Okay.
>> Your thoughts on ice? I don't know what that is, I genuinely
have no idea what that is. I don't know what you're talking about.
>> Here's the thing.
I do want unin people's uninformed take on politics. I do. I
want your uninformed take because guess what? Your uninformed
take is what you're taking to the voting booth. Right? Guess
what? Regardless of how informed somebody is, they get to vote.
You participate in politics. Okay? So, just give me your take.
I don't care if it's just tell me your take
or or you know, just ignore it.
Either one.
>> Like there's a certain extent where I'm like, "Okay,
sure. I get people wanting big content creators to like say their
opinions on like important topics. I get that, right? But it's
like
>> if you if you need a streamer who doesn't even know
anything about politics to tell you about politics, you probably
just need to like get off the internet. Like just stop. Like
>> she just denigrates people who want to know her opinion.
That's actually all she does here, right? That's that's what
she's actually doing. I don't care how informed she is. Who wants
her opinion anyway? I just I just explained this.
People who are who have this as a moral issue, who it's a moral
issue for them. If you support this kind of stuff, I don't want
to hang around with you, right? Like I'm I'm explaining this
to you in the easiest way. Let's say that, you know, we were
in the Jim Crow era and you decided like this is something we
could all agree is a moral issue, right?
um like equal rights between white and black people.
We could all agree that's a moral issue. You could take a moral
stand on that,
right? Right now it's it's like literally in debate, so it's
not the same. But that's a solved moral issue, right? We all
agree on that. So you could say back then, well, I don't want
to talk to anybody who supports like Jim Jim Crow regulations
or whatever, like like the separation of different races. I think
that's categorically wrong. If you if you support that, I don't
want to be friends with you.
And then if you you know, you hung out or you supported somebody
who is an entertainer, you could say, "I want to know your opinion
on this cuz I honestly if you don't if you're not on my side,
I kind of feel like it's a moral thing. I don't want to support
That's totally reasonable, right? I get wanting a politics free
zone. Then you don't answer the question. You don't talk about
the question. You don't bring up the question. You don't denigrate
people who think it's important because this is an inherently
political answer, right? It's an inherently political answer.
Oh, if you want my opinion, if you think it's a moral issue,
you need to get off the internet. You're a loser.
Okay?
It's an inherently political
Whether or not she wants to give political opinions, she is giving
political opinions, but you can't see it because it's an incontention
question right now. So, I'm trying to give you an example that
would allow you to understand that, hey,
and by the way, same thing with Jim Crow, same thing with not
having the equal equal rights between whites and blacks. If somebody
just said, well, I don't really look at any of that stuff. You
wouldn't take that as a real real answer. It was a real like
response. It wouldn't be it wouldn't be anything that's satisfying,
wouldn't be a real answer to the question,
right? And so I had a podcast with Emiru which I mean which I
think it's kind of it's ironic that people bring up steak and
eggs as like a point of like reference that oh this is how we
know Emu is like bad whenever Emmy was the one that wanted to
end the I'm just going to leak this right. She's the one that
wanted to not do steak and eggs anymore because she didn't want
to be involved with the the different like controversial stuff.
She didn't want to have anything to do with it. That was one
of that was a big reason.
the Israeli solution. Uh well, listen, Israel's in the strongest
position position it's been geopolitically in like its entire
history right now. Maybe there's something to that Israeli solution.
Okay, it was the main reason actually. That's it.
That's totally fair by the way. Like I I I was like like I I
I I was the one like she told me I I told Techone and that was
that was the end of it really. And so yeah, I totally understand
it. Oh, somebody just sent this to me. Apparently, Asmigold earlier
today said that he doesn't have a family because of OTK.
Asold and why OTK was his largest, most profound mistake in life.
Lots of reasons are personal that you don't even know. One example,
why I kept streaming contract obligations in the process. Neglected
a relationship, was going to move in, probably get married. >> I
mean this is the Pink Sparkles
>> in no form of exaggeration.
Starting OTK
was the most profound and largest mistake that I have ever made
in my entire life.
That's
I think that's total cap. That's like that's something you say
in retrospect when you don't like like something about your current
circumstances.
But I I think that's like a crazy thing to say when probably
the fact that he kept streaming has made it so that he and his
kids, any potential kids he has and any potential kids of his
kids will never have to work in their entire lives. I do think
that's like crazy. Now he's going to die alone. This is Yeah,
this is like obviously not happening, right?
like the idea that he's escaped the uh the loop that he's he's
broken away from the loop from the circle the infinite circle
of like working every day.
I I
you're never going to win when you go and say it was a mistake
to um to break free from the uh the chains of capitalism or whatever,
however you want to refer to it. That's one way to talk about
it. Like the fact that he doesn't have to work anymore, the fact
that you know his family, his his dad, his dad's dad, his dad's
dad, dad's dad's dad. Okay, they all had to work every single
day of their lives up until retirement, right? And Asmin Gold's
broken free of that. And then he's looking at it and he's like,
"Man, I really made mistakes." It's like, "No, you're not." Is
he even 30 yet? How old is Asmin Gold? What, like 31, 32? Asmin
Gold? 36. Okay, he's a little older than I thought, bro. You
could easily start a family at 36.
Come on, man.
You could super easily start a family at 36.
Be real. be real. >> Yep.
It was It was the biggest mistake I have ever made in >> Although
I will say I think he benefited maybe the least from OTK that
he started as an owner of OTK. He may have benefited the least
from OTK because he never went to any of the parties. He never
really interacted with a ton of those people, right? In a way
he couldn't have just being outside of the organization.
So maybe, but then I don't know, maybe taking breaks he's implying
he would have taken breaks and [__] I don't know.
Maybe if he was taking breaks and he would have, you know, fallen
off in some way in my whole life. >> Hard to say. And a
lot of the reasons for that
are personal reasons that you don't even
That's the truth.
And I'm glad both you and Tech respect our concerns. Well, I
don't want to speak for TechOne or anything like that. I have
no idea. But like to me, I mean, yeah, obviously like here's
the thing is that like the kind of content that I do is like
it's it's the same as like Hassan, right? I mean, this is it's
very opinionated. It's um it's radical in some cases. Uh it's
polarizing.
It's um you know, like uh it's divisive. And that's shockingly
like introspective
that he's like, "Oh, it's like Hassan that he normally talks
about how evil Hassan is he very often talks about how evil Hassan
is >> and he's like no my content is basically just like
Hassan >> a lot of people don't want to be involved with
that I mean that's just really the truth they don't want to be
involved with this and it's not about like that they agree with
it or disagree with it >> it's just that they don't want
to be involved like that's it they they >> give me one
second I'll be right >> it's too much for them they have
other things that they're worried about and you know people have
lives that exist outside of you know like Twitter likes and Twitter
comments and so I find it to be really uh really frustrating
to see that happen. Uh it's because people will be targeted.
Well, this is and this is what people like that do is that they
try to basically ma manufacture a false consensus through bullying
and fear on the internet because it's like, okay, well, we're
not going to listen to uh we're not going to listen to what you're
saying or anything like that. Uh we're going to do this just
because you don't agree with us. And the reason why they do that
is they're trying to manufacture a false consensus of everybody
online agreeing with them and repeating this to them so they
can create the narrative that everybody thinks the same thing.
And the reason why they're doing that is because they can't they
can't create a real consensus at the ballot box. They can't actually
mobilize politically. They can't actually get their political
ideas adopted by the population. So instead of all uh he says
that
unfortunately what I actually hear from him is well they're taking
like the right-wing approach that caused like the rightwing to
break towards populism and they're trying to apply that on the
left and I don't like that cuz it's worked really well in the
right wing and I don't like the idea that they're going to do
that on the left wing and so I I you know need to undercut that
in any way I can. That's what I hear when I hear him speak like
this. By the way, I don't like that the left is trying to adopt
like, you know, a lot a significant amount more populism. I personally
don't think it'll lead to good outcomes, but hey, >> that
what they would rather do.
>> I I don't know. I guess I've I've just seen what happens
with the right-wing populist, the Mala coalition feels like it
can't be worse than that. I don't know. We'll see. >> Is
they want to bully and make people afraid on the internet by
collectively harassing and abusing them for no reason other than
them saying, "I don't want to be involved." That's it. And they
try to manufacture a false consensus because they can't get a
real one. That's really what it is. I find it to be incredibly
disgusting and it's very obnoxious. So yeah, they want to control
Yeah. They want to That's it. That's fundamentally what they
want to do. They want to control you. They don't care about you.
They don't care about your feelings. They don't care about what
you want. They want to tell you what to say. They want to make
you say it. And if you say, "I don't want to play this game,"
they're going to treat you just like if you're on the other side.
That's it.
I find it to be very frustrating.
Uh I do think that's not far off from what Denims, Mike from
PA, VO, those people will do, right? I think it's not far off.
I also just think unfortunately
another thing as not considering here is how him and Techone
and a lot of people around them have sort of green lit all of
these like adjacent things that
right? Maybe not actually. Maybe not Asmin Gold. He seems to
be a lot more principled when it comes to this stuff. Okay. He
he actually does and I I'll give him his laurels on that. Okay.
That when when he can like go after somebody's friends who are
like supporting that when he can do that kind of thing, he tends
to not. All right. But Teone and a lot of people around Asmin
Gold, they don't give a [__] They'll go after those
people too. And so it's not shocking to me that when you know
Denims has, sorry, not Denims. when Amiru has professional relationships
with Akari, with Teetone, with Asminold that people will attach
her and attack her as if she's like a part of that coalition,
right? It just doesn't seem to me it just doesn't seem that confusing
or or concerning.
And I would say while he doesn't push that stuff himself, he's
a part of a coalition that does push that kind of stuff. And
he can't be shocked when it ends up biting him in the ass. >> It's
extremely frustrating. I hate him. I hate him. I hate him. And
and this is one of the reasons why I talk about the stuff that
I do. I find these people to be a prime evil in in discourse.
These people are the worst common denominator on discourse
coming down. Yeah. This is Listen, I I'll watch this later on.
I don't want to get into like all the details, but in general,
yeah, that's what I think about it. You go back to their weird
extremist. Of course, Demis would say you don't have to be informed.
Well, Denims is mad because Emiru said that Ethan Klein's lawsuits
against her were valid. That's the reason why Denims is mad about
this. It has nothing even >> Oh, hold on. We had an Asen
Gold viewer in here who was telling us about this.
Said, "Don't add Destiny." I think somebody somebody came in
and said, "Oh, this did happen >> about this." And she
even said this. This is the most like off-the- cuff comment that
you could have. And this for some reason, >> oh, hold on.
Denim's doubles down. Okay.
on calling Emiru a racist chud for not.
>> When did people on the right get soy?
You're smearing and defaming by calling someone a chud. No, it
tells me everything I need to know about the character of someone
who talks about things this way. I don't know why this I mean
it's it's it's intentional ignorance, but that's okay. It tells
me everything I need to know about this person. If you are fine
with commenting on things you don't know about when it benefits
you when you know your audience will like you talking about it.
Oh,
that's the Ethan Klein lawsuit, right? That's that is objectively
the Ethan Klein lawsuit. I do not think that's wrong. I do not
think that's wrong at all. Right. Like Emiru didn't mind commenting
on the Ethan Klein lawsuit saying, "Oh, well, you know, those
people were malicious. Those were malicious reactors." I don't
think that's an incorrect critique that that Amiru didn't know
what she was saying. She didn't she didn't have a lot of background
there. She was perfectly happy to talk about it. And now when
it might affect your audience when it's not something your audience
wants to hear, YOU GO, "WHOA, WHY SHOULD I have to comment on
that guys? Oh, that's a that's an even better critique that I
gave. Thank you, Denn. Oh, wow. That's
>> That's one thing.
But then for you to use an opportunity or ignore an opportunity
I get all my political takes from
uh by the way this is almost nothing to do with like political
takes. It's it's like it's not that people want political advice
from Emiru. Just so we're clear. Everybody should understand
that nobody wants political advice from Emiru. Anybody framing
it that way is a who can't pay attention or is intentionally
trying to frame things in a way that defends Emiru automatically.
That's those are the people who say people who say that, right?
That's what they're trying to do >> where you could talk
about something. Maybe your audience doesn't like it. Maybe you
could educate them on it a little bit, but you choose not to.
You're just siding with whatever your chud or chudet audience
wants to hear.
>> Yeah. Amir can educate people on this. I don't believe
that. But >> she's right when she says most streamers are
not qualified to talk about politics. Okay, here's the thing,
dude. Um, you actually don't have to be qualified to talk about
politics to say ICE. It's not that hard of a concept.
Uh, hold on. I'm I'm being told there's a misk tweet. Hold on.
[__] Ice. Yo, bro. Ice dog. Ice dog.
You love to see it. You love to see it. We're on the >> You
know who doesn't do political content? Cutie Cinderella. Cutie
Cinderella literally never does political content. And even she's
capable of saying ice. What about SA? These are You don't have
to be a political creator to recognize that it's not hard to
say ICE. And I don't know if you know this.
If you're an adult in this country, you should be the minimal
amount invested in politics
because you live here. There's this weird idea in America especially
where like you can just be an adult and be like, "Oh, I don't
care about politics." What? If you're above the age of 18, you
should care about politics in your [__] All I need
is I need Trump to do this, okay, before he leaves office. I
need people to be able to um like sign away their right to vote.
They don't get any advantage to it, but influencers need to sign
away their right to vote and then they can go, I don't care about
politics. I' I've I've opted to be like a, you know, cattle slave
in this country. I've opted to be cattle in this country. I don't
want my vote. I actually don't want it anymore. And then you
go, I don't care about politics. I'm just I'm just like a [__]
I'm just a you
debating bimbo and you don't have to you don't don't expect politics
talk here. Okay. We don't talk about anything serious here. You
could do that if you want. If you want to sign away your autonomy
like that otherwise you have a vote and you should be you should
care about politics. Okay. You shouldn't get to go I don't I
don't talk about politics. I don't think about politics. That's
bad. That's bad. I If you don't care about the culture war, that's
also fine, right? Let's let's be real. If you didn't care about
like the culture war, you didn't care about trans issues, but
you should care about politics
in general enough to know that you who you're voting for and
why you're voting every year, every whatever two years
you don't get to be like, well, I don't agree with this whole
taxes thing,
so I'm just not going to pay for it.
You can't say like, well, I'm just not going to care about all
this politics stuff. This is by far like the I think
American quality
saying I'm not into
>> I do think that's it's not the dumbest. It's just like
a cover your ass thing in this case. I don't believe for a second
that she's just not into politics at all. I just don't I don't
believe it, man. I don't believe it.
Seems like a total lie.
All right, we're back to this the Asmin Gold Defense of Emir.
Okay. carrying that, you know, like the chip on her shoulder
for like a a year now or something, right? And so that's it.
>> And uh it's just it's awful to really see that happen,
man. And uh is allegedly being paid. Uh well, I don't know, right?
I have no idea if anybody's being paid or anything like that,
but uh you know, wait. And it's just it's awful to really see
that happen, man. And uh is allegedly being paid. Uh >> Denims
is allegedly being paid by the man who shall not be named to
attack Emiru.
Oh, allegedly. Oh, he read this.
Denovs is being paid by Mythkip to attack Emirou. I don't think
so. I kind of doubt it. I personally very much doubt it. Okay.
Oh, I don't know, right? I have no idea if anybody's being paid
or anything like that, but uh you know, again, I I don't I don't
know. But yeah, that's generally that's my that's my two cents
on it, right? That's my two cents. It's ridiculous. Uh nobody
has to give their political opinion if they don't want to. What
happened to streaming for fun? Well, that's the reason why they
do it. You see, like that's the whole point is that they want
to bully people into thinking that they have to in order to say
that. And uh it's very annoying. It is. >> And it seems
like more than two sentences. It is. It is. Like I I'm very opinionated
about this. I I find it to be like this is the kind of stuff
that I think is the most important thing to talk about. And the
reason why is because this is the kind of toxic bully behavior
that I don't think anybody should tolerate on any side of the
spectrum. Like it doesn't matter whether it's like, you know,
oh, somebody has to speak out for Charlie Kirk or somebody has
to, you know, say that ICE is bad or you have to say that say
BLM. Like it's all the same. It's all the same. It is a a bully
culture that >> Wait, you have to say Charlie Kirk is bad?
People just said that before
people Wait, hold on, hold on, wait. Oh, Ashenold just cooked
up the next point.
Uh, how dare you say that Charlie Kirk was a fascist? How dare
you say that Charlie Kirk was bad? He just got shot for being
a political streamer, for being somebody who makes Tik Tok clips.
He just got shot.
Say nightstands about Charlie Kirk now or we're going to get
you fired from your job. Don't say anything bad about Charlie
Kirk or we'll get you fired from your job. Like, why are we pretending
that this doesn't fit Asmin Gold's audience? That Asmin Gold
wasn't in this precise mode for weeks after Charlie Kirk got
shot. It's It's crazy, man. That forces compliance. And if you
do not agree, you're treated like the enemy. If you're not with
us, you're against us. And And I think that fundamentally is
a huge problem. It's an awful problem. And so that's it. And
uh joining. Yeah. So, who would say ice is bad? I mean, I I'll
say before and that's what I find to be odd is like I mean there's
a million more comments about other people, but like I mean I'm
saying it's good. I've said this many times. So, like where's
the comments about me? You know, that's it. Phil only cares.
Uh Asmin Gold supported and amplified a site that maintained
doc's information of people who had said even just bad things
about Charlie Kirk. Even just saying like I don't care that this
guy got hit or something, this guy was a fascist. that like like
there were some very mild comments or just straight up jokes
on that website and they were looking to dox people to inform
their employers that they were celebrating the death of Charlie
Kirk. Okay. No, it was not just attacking woke people. That's
gay. That's wrong. Cares about two things. Language and power.
Yeah, absolutely. That falls apart eventually though. They turn
on themselves. Oh, they always do. But in the process of that,
it's unpleasant to watch it unfold. And so that's really the
point I was making. >> Comply with the government when
I agree with them. when the government says that like trans kids
can get steroids, can get uh hormones. No, no, no. Fight the
government at any cost. Okay? Fight the government at any cost.
It's just transparently I just support my own politics. It's
very obvious, right? And by the way, I don't support the trans
hormone stuff for for kids. Like, I don't necessarily support
a ton of that stuff. I'm just saying it's pretty obvious. Just
comply when it's the stuff I agree with. When it's the stuff
I don't agree with, oh, you can fight that all the way to the
grave. Okay.
Exactly. Oh, also thank you very much Ruben Ruben for the donation
like the say free Palestine. Like there's most people don't even
know where Palestine is. So like how are they supposed to go
and say that or have an opinion on it whenever they're not even
informed? So uh that's really what I would say. It's basically
elementary schoolyard. Whose side are you on? Yep. They know
they can't control you through bullying. That >> uh Yeah.
People could be civily disobedient about it. Yes. Yep.
>> It's exactly it. And so they move on to >> and
then I think you could, you know, whatever their civil disobedience
is, you could arrest them for it if it was it was something you
could arrest them for, right? I the only thing I would say is
if a right-winger was mad that you were like, you know, offering
healthcare to trans kids and they, you know, blocked a highway,
I would say arrest them. Don't shoot them in the head. Obviously
to the next target because you're right, they're not going to
get anything out of me because they tried and they tried for
years. But at the end of the day, that's the reason why they
do it is because they think they can get a result. And it's disappointing
to see that. It's the most cynical and hostile thing out there.
[snorts] But anyway,
let's see here. Ask a German subreddit asked if ICE is comparable
to the Nazis. The results are what you would say. All toprated
comments are saying yes. It's the same with anything contrary
to that being deleted. And any comment saying this is uh uh is
actually very dis disrespectful and downplaying actual crimes
of the Nazis. You're being deleted or downvoted into oblivion.
Yeah. I mean this this is the kind of stuff that I'm talking
about. I mean like really like you can think that ICE is bad
and you can disagree and dislike ICE and think they should be
removed and you can think everything like that. You can have
every libtart opinion that you want. But to say that they're
the same as the Gestapo or the Nazis, I mean this is just crazy.
Like they used to use for medical testing as pigs. Like it's
just not even in the same I mean the Gestapo didn't the Gestapo
just went and captured them universe as deporting somebody who
they think is in the country illegally to another country. Like
it's really a total it's a completely different situation.
It's a totally I mean Gestapo secret police uh what did they
secret police is Russia right? Is the USSR like you you could
just I mean people do these illusions all the time. And they
do these like metaphors all the time. It's not really that far
off. Different world. And again, I I could see things changing.
Maybe things change in 50 years or 100 years. But do you want
to make decisions on what could be or do you want to make a decisions
on what is? I think you should make decisions on what is. And
so that's really how I see it. Anything new on Pipa and company
on following you? So I did see this. Uh let me talk about this
a little bit. So I did hear that. Where did it come from? Where
did it go? >> that seems like natural allyship. Why would
they be fighting with each other? >> Oh, I think it's it's
not this. Um, okay. Yeah. Yeah. Here we go. I I I thought I think
it was on Yeet. So, a lot of the people at FaZe Connect are unhappy
about the fact that Yeah. Here it is. FaZe Connect is rumored
to have had their talents unfollow Asmin Gold on social after
Pippa went viral for doing so.
So,
I don't know anything about this. Like, and I'm gonna let y'all
know like this is the kind of stuff I think about,
[laughter] Apparently, Pipa is taking some left turn.
got to respect the instincts. Got to respect the grifting instincts
on Pipa Pipkin. Okay, she saw the right-wing grift as it was
coming in. She caught early on in the wave. Okay,
rode that to massive success and she sees it shifting again and
she starts shifting. You got to respect the instincts, man. That's
some impressive. She can see the winds are turning. She can see
that it's shifting. And she gets in early again. My god. Am I
worried about who's following me on social media? I wouldn't
even notice something like that. Can you believe that? This is
what people like this do. These are adults that are doing this.
They're saying, "You got to unfollow somebody. You got to do
something." That is embarrassing, man. I can't believe it. They're
crying hard. So apparently PC, that's um uh FaZe >> Uh
apparently Asold doxed a VTuber. Was it a FaZe Connect VTuber
for badmouthing Charlie Kirk? Is that is that what he's talking
about when he's talking about how it's in line with his values?
>> Now you might disagree with it. You might think that
well you didn't do the right thing, but from my point of view,
from like my value system, I think I did the right thing. And
the truth is that
hold on
asold doxes phase connect talent Kaminari Clara live on stream.
Not going to link it for obvious reasons but it started with
a post in the asoldold subreddit notifying notifying of phase's
latest announcement. The poster then added info about Claraara's
political beliefs at the end. Oh, is this r/asmold or about Clara's
political beliefs at the end and it ends up with her being full
doxed again and now to a much larger audience. It's today's VOD.
If you want to dig, go for it. So yesterday apparently he full
doxed somebody in the face connect space. Oh well that that seems
pretty up. Uh oh somebody like this. It's worth the cost of the
gun deaths for the second amendment. So she did the exact same
thing a bunch of other people did were like oh look at these
Charlie Kirk comments. We're going to laugh about these Charlie
Kirk comments that seem to have come back and bit him in the
ass even though it's like not really actually accurate at all
and that I don't think he feels like it was it was hypocritical
or anything. that he would agree that you should still have your
second amendment even though he got shot.
Okay. All right. So, this happened. Why did Asminold?
>> All right. Do we need to go into more of how he doxed
this person precisely?
>> Whenever you have a >> We'll listen to a little
bit more of this right now and then we might look into how he
docked her precisely. >> I I hope that the people in Phase
Connect see this and they listen to what I'm saying in an honest
and genuine way.
You had a person in your org who was celebrating the death of
a man being shot in the neck for talking.
He wasn't advocating for genocide. He wasn't hurting anyone.
He wasn't breaking the law. He um I mean I think that's wrong.
But even if he was, you know, advocating for genoc
stop. Even if he were doing those things, I don't know. Depending
on which one of those things he was doing, sorry. you wouldn't
have the right to kill him, right?
But I I just it's so annoying that he says this and then I feel
compelled to correct him that Charlie Kirk was not some, you
know, just somebody talking. That's not that's not true. Had
a m massive amount of political influence was putting that behind
a an administration that is obviously violating a bunch of rights
of Americans or American residents. Right.
Right. He was sitting there of no threat to anyone else. He didn't
have a weapon. He did nothing and he was shot and executed in
front of a massive crowd of people and just for the pure reason
of having the wrong opinion. That is wrong. It's a disgusting
thing. That's a terrible thing. Nobody should be supporting that.
Nobody should be agreeing with that. Nobody should be rationalizing
that. And above everything else, nobody should be encouraging
that.
and one of your own did that. That's the wrong thing to do. You
shouldn't do that. And so when I call that out and I say you
shouldn't do that.
I'm not being a bad guy. I'm not the bad guy here. They are.
And so I see this Joel did nothing wrong.
Okay. Okay. So
Azold apparently docks this person. Apparently I would like to
see where that is where he like pulled up her information. I
just like to see exactly how it happened. Looking through his
previous vod trying to find this guy literally she wished for
miscarriage and death on someone. The type of people like that
again they're bullies. They're they're internet bullies and they're
hostile aggressive bad people. You're mourning more than Erica.
I don't care about Erica Kirk. Why the would I care about Erica
Kirk? Like I I don't give a what what she does. It doesn't matter
to me. Like it it I don't like the only reason that anybody even
knows her name is because of Charlie Kirk. Like, why the do I
care if she's crying or not? Like, I I'm going to purity test
some random woman. I don't give a about her. Who cares about
her?
What do you think? Really? Like, I look Look, I I I'm an
wrong.
I'm not wrong about this.
So, >> you're wrong about a lot of the things surrounding
this for sure. >> And uh anyway, objectivity. Yeah. Exactly.
Right. People are crazy. So, I go and I I call this person out
and I I I'm the aggressor. I'm the bad guy. I don't think so.
I'm not the bad guy. I'm not the aggressor. I'm the person that
is holding those people back. I'm the person who's holding them
accountable. And I know that it might feel bad to have one of
your own have that happen to them. But I want to let you know
that they absolutely deserved it. And if somebody advocated for
that on a family member of yours, you'd be agreeing with me.
And that's it. So, and uh and no, people like Charlie Kirk mourn
in all different ways. I don't want to get into that. Did that
apparently a crazy girl said on her personal account, people
found out after they doxed her. You cannot dox a person who had
a public image and then changed to having another public image.
Doxing is revealing private information.
Oh god, we're going to actually run into this totally
cope again. Uh it depends. I mean maybe there might be if she
basically was using her like face with the name there there is
you know another element of doxing is connecting a public image
to private information or or connecting you know a public social
media page basically somebody's somebody's identity to a pseudonymous
account that is also doxing right
the idea of doxing is you're going to publish information on
somebody that will make them fear for their safety you're maliciously
collecting and publishing information that will put them in fear
for their safety in some way or put them in fear of getting harassed
in some way. Yeah.
Right. That's that's what doxing is. Doxing is showing a person's
address. It's giving their phone number or something like
uh which is what the left has always done it. Why I move more
center. What was your thoughts on doxing people who made jokes
about Charlie Kirk dying? Sarius. Surious.
How'd you feel about that? Let me guess. That was totally justified
and not cancel culture at all. Right. Right. Totally justified.
Absolutely not in any way cancel culture or did you move more
to the left again? Right. More away from the center towards the
left when a bunch of right-wingers are like, "Oh, we actually
need to get these people fired. We actually need to dox and get
these people fired immediately." You joked, you joked about Charlie
Kirk getting shot. Uh, no. You need to be fired. Get this guy
fired.
Do we love cancel culture in that case?
Because I got bad news for you if you love cancel culture in
that case. Okay, that it's not saying, "Hey, this other thing
that you posted publicly, maybe this is the same person." That's
not doxing. If you think that's doxing, you're trying to you're
bas
Now, I will say Asmin Gold's argument that is doxing. That is
doxing in this case, right? You you saw the full name when you
when you Googled it. you clicked through and you like were reading
it. You had it up on your screen. You didn't go, "Oh, oops."
Nothing like that. >> Trying to do by saying that it's
doxing is you're trying to like water.
>> Okay. Sultarius, you're trying to redirect. I'm asking
very specifically about the first one. Did that put you off of
being like uh more central more centrist leaning when they went
and did it for jokes, which they did do. There are many cases
where it's jokes and people are explicitly like getting docks
for that, right? Did that put you off of like hanging out with
these communities being, you know, more centrist?
I would hope so. Down the word so you can act like a victim.
You're absolutely not a victim. That's not the case. Whenever
you make public statements and you do things like that and you
had previously released other information into the public, this
is all released into the public voluntarily
and uh on their own. They decided to do this. They consented
to having this information public. When I show somebody public
information that that individual consented to being made public,
that's literally everybody. Literally everybody in the modern
modern age has a Facebook account or an Instagram account or
LinkedIn account. You could always find some public page people
have that you could link to them and dox them. You
the fact literally all doxing is done with public information.
If you own property, you have public information out there. If
you've ever been in a phone book, you have public information
out there. Literally all of this is public information.
All doxing is done with public information.
Obviously,
there's not a single person who lives like the uni bomber who's
ever been doxed.
Okay?
Just be real. That is not doxing.
It's not. It's ridiculous. It's ridiculous thing to accuse somebody
of. Of course, it's not true. I would never do that.
you know, getting people like this like and also I want to say
that I'm trying to help your or I'm trying to help you guys.
I'm not a virus, but I'm also not a disease. I'm the inoculation.
I'm not a virus, but I'm also not a
Classic Asmin Gold classic. That's a classic one right there.
You might say that I am a little mean, but it's better that I'm
a little bit mean and I hold people accountable for doing something
that's bad than for you to have this disease metastasize
and then fester and get worse.
So, you should be saying thank you if
and you're welcome by the way. You're welcome.
So, Calpus, yeah, that's it. JD Vance moment. Okay. Have you
guys even said thank you? Have you even said thank you to Asthmold,
guys? Have you even Have you even said thank you? >> And
you're not mean. Yeah, exactly. You're welcome. I I did this
for you and it's completely free. I don't need any payment. You
don't need to give me money. You don't need to say thank you
on social media. I will accept just simply you acting different.
That's it. Thank you. Exactly. Have you said thank you once?
They never do, do they? They're so ungrateful.
And uh lifting weights is a bit painful, but it's good for you.
Yeah, maybe I should do that, too. I did. So, okay. I I
I should Oh, God. Oh, no. No. No. As a gold, anything but that.
If I have to react to Asmin Gold red pill content about how he
changed his life by going to the gym and getting on TRT, I will
end it. Okay. If you wanted to end this stream, Asold, if you
wanted to end me specifically, you could do that today. You you
get a TRT prescription. You start bulking up. You head to the
gym and you start talking about how it changed your life and
how being offline more changed your life. You you take a techone
arc. I will end it. I will do it. I promise you. Okay. Please,
for the love of God, do not.
This guy 30-day
shower challenge. So, in January, I did something that a lot
of people don't
I took a 30-day shower challenge.